>> Tucker: AS WE LOOK AROUND
THE UNITED STATES, WE OFTEN
THINK IT HAS A BETTER COUNTRY
EVER BEEN LED BY WAS PEOPLE?
PROBABLY NOT.
SO WE HAVE LOOK AROUND THE WORLD
AND WE TRIED FROM TIME TO TIME
TO BRING LEADERS FROM OTHER
COUNTRY WHO ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
THEIR PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHEN WE WENT TO HUNGARY
TO TALK TO VIKTOR ORBAN.
WE SPOKE TO HIM AND HE MENTIONED
OTHER COUNTRIES IN CENTRAL
EUROPE THAT HAVE DEFENDED THEIR
POPULATIONS AGAINST
INTERNATIONAL INTERFERENCE.
ONE OF THE COUNTRIES HE
MENTIONED WAS POLAND.
IN BUDAPEST, I HAVE RUN INTO A
NUMBER OF AMERICANS WHO HAVE
COME HERE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
BE AROUND PEOPLE WHO AGREED WITH
THEM, AGREED WITH YOU, DO YOU
SEE BUDAPEST AS KIND OF CAPITAL
OF THIS KIND OF THINKING?
>> THE CAPITAL OF THAT KIND OF
THINKING OR ONE OF THE CAPITALS
THEY ARE ALSO VERY COMPETITIVE
AND PRODUCING GREATNESS IDEAS
AND ORGANIZING THE KIND OF
COMMUNITIES OF CONSERVATIVE AND
CHRISTIAN DEMOCRATS.
>> Tucker: ANDRZEJ DUDA IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE OLYMPIC
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING S.
WE KNOW YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES
AND YOU'RE WATCHING THIS MASSIVE
FLOW OF MIGRANTS.
IT WILL TOTAL OVER A MILLION
THIS YEAR.
SOMETHING SIMILAR HAPPENED TO
EUROPE IN 2015.
DE YOU PRESSURED POLAND OTHER
NATIONS TO ACCEPT AND POLAND
FOUGHT BACK.
TELL US WHAT YOU DID THAT.
>> Translator: THE ANSWER IS
SIMPLE.
WE DID NOT AGREE IN 2015 THROUGH
THE SO-CALLED QUOTA SYSTEM.
IT MEANS THAT EVERY SINGLE
COUNTRY WOULD HAVE TO ACCEPT A
GIVEN NUMBER OF MIGRANTS.
WE GIVE A CLEAR ANSWER TO THAT.
WHOEVER WANTS TO COME TO
POLITICAL WHOEVER IS LOOKING FOR
HELP, ASSISTANCE, ESPECIALLY
REFUGEES LOOKING FOR SHELTER
BECAUSE THEY ARE THREATENED BY
WORKUPS PERSECUTED IN THEIR OWN
COUNTRIES, IF THEY WANT TO COME
TO POLAND, WE WANT THEM TO STAY
IN POLAND LIVE IN POLAND TICKETS
BUT TO ACCEPT SUCH A PERSON AND
HELP THEM, WE DO NOT AGREE TO
RELOCATE POLAND PEOPLE BY FORCE.
WE DO NOT AGREE TO KEEP THESE
PEOPLE IN PRISONS BUT IF THESE
PEOPLE DID NOT WANT TO STAY IN
POLAND.
THEY WOULD WANT TO LEAVE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE
ANYBODY'S DAY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO KEEP ANYBODY
AGAINST POINT.
VAX THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT, JOE
BIDEN, BEFORE HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, DESCRIBED POLAND AS
UNFREE -- AUTHORITARIAN PLACE.
HOW HAVE YOUR DEALINGS WITH THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BEEN SINCE
HE HAS BECOME PRESIDENT?
CAP YOU JUST SAID IT WOULD BE A
VERY FORGETTABLE THING.
THERE'S A LOT OF LIES.
>> ABOUT POLAND.
SOME REPRESENTATIVES ARE SAYING
ABOUT THE CURRENT POLAND'S
GOVERNMENT IS TOTALLY UNTRUE.
THE BEST PROOF OF THAT IS ONE OF
THE FACTS THAT THE INCUMBENT
GOVERNMENT HAS WON THE ELECTION.
THEY WON THE TEMPTING BACK IN
2019 PROGRESS AT THE PEOPLE ARE
HAPPY WITH THEIR GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW.
THEY THINK DISC GOVERNMENT CARES
FOR THEIR INTEREST.
THIS IS WHY THEY WERE REELECTED.
AND SOME ARE FURIOUS.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO WIN
ELECTIONS.
AND THEY LOST TWICE IN A ROW.
THEY ALSO LOST THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
LET ME REITERATE, IT IS THE
PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT POLAND'S FAMILY POLICY.
SO POLAND FROM THE OUTSIDE
APPEARS TO HAVE DECIDED TO HELP
ENCOURAGE POLISH COUPLES TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
PLEASE TELL US WHAT YOU ARE
DOING AND WHAT YOU HAVE DONE IT.
TRE THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT
MARRIAGE IS THAT UNIT OF A MAN
AND A WOMAN AND A FAMILY.
THE FIRST TIME SINCE 1980 MEANT
THAT WE HAVE EMBARKED UPON A
GREAT RESOLUTE AND FAST
PROFAMILY ACTION.
WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2015, I ALSO MADE A PLEDGE
AND I SAID THAT WE WOULD START A
PROFAMILY POLICY.
WE OFFERED, WE ACTUALLY
ANNOUNCED MYSELF DURING THE
CAMPAIGN AND LATER I WAS JOINED
BY MY COLLEAGUES WHO WERE ALSO
ABUTTING THE EFFECT THE ELECTION
TO BE PLEDGING THAT WE WOULD
INTRODUCE THE PROGRAM BY THE
NAME OF 500 PRIZE.
WE WERE TESTING, ACTUALLY.
WE DECIDED IT STARTED FROM THE
SECOND CHILD AND FAMILY.
THE PRINCE OF EVERY CHILD WOULD
RECEIVE 500 -- POP ART SOME OF
$130.
THE KIND OF WORK FOR THE FRONT
MANY FROM THE STATE IN RAISING
CHILDREN.
THIS WAS REVOLUTIONIZED AND
POLAND I THINK NOBODY CAN
IMAGINE THAT TO NOT TO HAVE TO
500 PLUS PROGRAM IN POLITICAL IT
IS THE BEST SOCIAL PROGRAM WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO INTRODUCE.
BUT A POLITICIAN SPEAKING
OPENLY, I CONSIDER MY SELF TO BE
RATHER CONSERVATIVE AND
ACTUALLY, WAS ALWAYS FRANK ABOUT
MY VIEWS.
I'M A CHRISTIAN.
I'M A PRACTICING CHRISTIAN.
I PRAY.
I'M NOT ASSUMED THAT WHATSOEVER.
TO ME, THAT'S VALUE OF THE
FAMILY IS PRICELESS.
I'M PRO-LIFE.
I DEFEND LIFE.
I BELIEVE THAT LIFE IS SACRED.
I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE GUARDED.
AND FAMILY TO DOES HAVE TO BE
SUPPORTED AS STRONG AS THEY CAN
BECAUSE FAMILY IS THE
FOUNDATION OF EVERY NATION.
THE SUPPORT WITH WHICH WE
OFFERED FAMILIES WITH EIGHT
POLITICAL PERSPECTIVE IS KEY
IMPORTANCE.
WE ALSO HAVE USED OTHER PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING FAMILIES.
WAS A PART PARENTS WITH THE BOOK
CHILD STARTING SCHOOL WITH
PROGRAMS, -- SO WE TAKE 300 TO
THE PARENT OF EVERY CHILD GOING
TO SCHOOL TO BUY A SET OF BOOKS.
PENCILS, STATIONERY.
WHATEVER THE CHILD NEEDS.
OPERA THAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
MOMENT WHEN THE SCHOOL YEAR
BEGINS.
FAMILIES HAVE TO SPEND MORE
MONEY.
TURNS OUT 300 IS IMPORTANT.
IT ALSO CONTRIBUTES QUITE BIG
SUPPORT ON TOP OF THE 500 PLUS
WHICH EVERY FAMILY GETS PER
CHILD.
>> Tucker: INSPIRING TO HIM AT
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR SITTING DOWN AND
TALKING TO US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD TO SEE Y